and the worst thing that we can do today
in this recession is to limit the
potential energy in our businesses by
over taxing them over regulating them
prohibiting entrepreneurs from starting
new businesses and unfortunately our
government does that at the state
federal and local levels all the time
I'm Tim Sandefur I'm a principal
attorney at the Pacific Legal Foundation
headquartered in California and I'm the
author of the right to earn a living
economic freedom in the law my book
focuses on the history of the right to
make one's own economic choices the
right to economic freedom which was
protected by English and American courts
as far back as the 17th century and was
well understood and highly regarded by
the founding fathers and is a central
part of the Liberty that the
Constitution protects you know a lot of
time you hear people talk about the
economic freedom as an unenumerated
right well it's not an unenumerated
right Liberty is an enumerated right in
the Constitution and Liberty includes
the right to make one's own choices
about a variety of things including the
right to make economic choices what to
buy and sell what to earn what jobs to
take or not take and that sort of thing
what happened during the New Deal was a
the climax of a gradual transformation
of the law often we talk about the New
Deal as being a sudden change in
American law but what it really was was
the constitutional is a ssin of the
philosophy of progressivism of the
progressive interpretation of the
Constitution that began around the end
of the 19th century the beginning of the
20th century and it began with people
like all the Lindo homes or louis
brandeis who were at first were writing
dissenting opinions right holmes
famously dissented in the case of
Lochner versus New York Brandeis wrote
all these famous dissenting opinions in
1934 what happened is that their ideas
became American law and there were four
big progressive ideas the first one was
that was that rights are just
permissions rights aren't you don't you
aren't entitled to rights because your
human rights are something society gives
you for its own purposes the second idea
was that government exists to make
society nice
the founders thought that government
exists only to protect individual rights
but the progressives came up with all
sorts of new ideas for how to make
society nice and eugenics prohibition
segregation income tags all of these
wonderful new ideas for how to control
society and make it better
zoning we talked about eminent domain
for instance it was the progressives who
first used the word blight to describe
neighborhoods began blight originally is
the determinant for a plant disease
right
but the progressives used it to talk
about neighborhoods because they imagine
society as a plant and government as the
gardener that goes around and prunes the
garden and makes it nice
the third great progressive idea was
judicial restraint that when government
decides to violate your rights
courts should do nothing about it and
then the fourth great progressive idea
was the living Constitution so those
four progressive ideas became American
law in 1934 in a case called nebula in
the versus New York and in nebia what
the court did was it invented the so
called rational basis test rational
basis means government does whatever it
wants and gets away with it as long as
some politician thought it was a good
idea
the thing is constitutional as the
rational basis test and since 1934 to
the present day that's the test that's
applied when it comes to economic
freedom or private property rights now
when you're talking about rights that
the Left cares about things like freedom
of speech you tend to get a higher level
of protection from courts but when we're
talking about economic liberty and
private property rights courts simply
look the other way and in the vast
majority of cases there are exceptions
of course but because of the rational
basis test which is nowhere to be found
in the Constitution because of that
people's economic freedoms in this
country are at risk for some legislators
that can do whatever they want
I'd love time on Nebbia because it's
such an incredibly stupid decision what
happens is 1934 the the depths of the
Great Depression unemployment is like 25
percent or something and the state of
New York of course knows how to solve
this problem obviously the solution is
right before our eyes and that is you
have to make food more expensive right
so that's what they do they pass a law
saying you're not allowed to charge less
than I believe it's 8 cents a quart
milk and Leo never Rochester grocery
store owner sales notes is brought up on
charges for it and the US Supreme Court
says yeah you can you can punish him for
that because if the government wants to
regulate the economy it can do virtually
anything it wants to so the rational
basis test that was basically concocted
out of thin air by the progressive
movement and gradually but applied to
American law with no constitutional
basis that's why you have cases like
kilo or these these law licensing
restrictions that prohibit people from
earning of an honest living what are the
primary abuses of economic liberties I
would say the most obvious one is
antitrust law which is a murky swamp of
precedent that nobody can interpret or
understand that where the same behavior
can be characterized as a
pro-competitive good thing for the
consumer or as an anti-competitive crime
against the people depending entirely on
spin and on how broadly you draw the
circle an example that I give in the
book about this is when the Nestle
corporation tried to buy Dreyer's ice
cream now for Nestle to buy dryers is
obviously not a monopoly in the ice
cream business there's plenty of ice
cream manufacturers and there's no
problem so what the Federal Trade
Commission did was it simply created a
new category of ice cream that it called
super premium ice cream which I guess
means really good ice cream in which
case there's only dryers and Breyers and
now it's a monopoly for Nestle to buy
dryers you see so it depends entirely on
how broadly you decide to characterize
the market you can create a defense
against the laws of the United States
I'm currently representing a moving
company in Missouri in a lawsuit where
the licensing law in Missouri says if
you want to start a moving company you
first have to get permission from all
the existing moving companies what
happens is you apply for a permit and
the government notifies all the existing
moving companies and gives them the
opportunity to object and if they object
you have to go to a board of bureaucrats
and prove to them that there ought to be
a new moving company how do you prove
that there ought to be a new moving
company before Starbucks went into
business how could they have proved to
anybody that we need a new coffee shop
wouldn't you have said there's plenty of
coffee shops out there so it's
impossible
prove this what it does is it gives
existing businesses the opportunity to
prevent fair competition from
entrepreneurs in a business that is a
prime example of the kind of entry-level
business that immigrants and the poor
tend to gravitate to and this is a point
that unfortunately a lot of liberals
tend to ignore which is that the people
who need constitutional protection for
economic Liberty the most are the poor
and members of minority groups it's not
rich white guys who are driving taxi
cabs unfortunately just about all the
Supreme Court justices are hostile to
the idea of economic Liberty with the
possible exception of Justice Clarence
Thomas but they even just as Thomas
treats the idea of protecting rights
under the Due Process Clause with
unwarranted skepticism and as a result
even even he is questionable in the
question of economic freedom on during
the oral argument in McDonald vs Chicago
one of the justices asked well if we
restore the privileges or immunities
clause why wouldn't that mean we'd be
protecting economic liberties as though
this is a damming question to which the
answer is yes of course and the
Constitution does protect economic
liberty economic Liberty was the first
thing mentioned in the 1866 Civil Rights
Act which was passed before the 14th
amendment by the same Congress and for
the same reasons and unfortunately the
justices you know they know very well
that the New Deal precedents that
abandoned protections for economic
Liberty are central to the regulatory
welfare state that we have today and
there they are their primary loyalty is
to preserving the regulatory welfare
state and not enforcing the Constitution
of the United States